okay free whenever you're ready I'll hug
you and squeeze you and kiss you and put
coins in your eyes that's why we don't
be kids names dough for Elmo I am guru
Akash welcome to the city of Atlantis
Angelica you know that you're mean to
those babies and I've had enough I will
not let you bother them again works for
me
[Music]
this is Cree summer and her voice it's
kind of legendary I am best known for
being penny from Inspector Gadget follow
and grainy look suspicious Inspector
Gadget are you all right Susie
Carmichael who really stood up the end
I'm Angelica and took care of those
babies and I play em now was the real
princess Kida from the lost city of
Atlantis
look eagle man there you go there's the
taster so my great is it
I knew uncle gadget would never rob a
bank let's say I started voice acting
when I was 11 years old my father Don
Frank's was the voice of sabertooths
from the x-men he also had the very
first person to ever voice and vocal
effect from Star Wars which is such a
cool ass thing and he had already been
cast on Inspector Gadget and he asked if
they would be kind enough to read to his
daughter and they said sure we'll give
her a shot and it literally took off
like wildfire from there my name's Susie
I know / Susie one of the most important
things was that she found smart and that
she's very well spoken because there
were not a lot of brown girls and
cartoons as a matter of fact they're
still learned beyond all this Cree is
unique for another reason
historically white voice actors
generally did the voices for cartoon
characters of all races trees thrived in
the space that is often overlooked
people who look like her oh come on boys
I just put on two mothballs
I mean let's face it I'd do the voices
of all the brown girls and all the
animated Brown girls but still ain't
that many because there's this really
crazy belief that black girls don't
lords cartoons and then we don't collect
comics and then we don't like sci-fi and
that's the SMAN
we love it I love when people of color
come up to me and say you don't know
what it meant to me to see myself in a
cartoon I got one little black girl that
I get to see that looks like me thank
you so much I get off on this guy
[Music]
you